hi and welcome back to Sara's music I'm
on the Upper West Side of New York today
at the Lincoln Center to my left is the
Avery Fisher Hall home of the New York
Philharmonic to my right that David H
Koch theater home of the New York City
Ballet and behind me is the mighty
Metropolitan Opera the biggest Opera
House are probably the most famous in
the world we're going inside today to
take a look
hello lot of work keeping an opera house
clean right a lot of work
we're inside the Met and it's so
beautiful here and it's huge
3800 seats 195 standing room places and
if you're sitting right up there in the
gods it's so far away that you'll
definitely need your binoculars but it
sounds amazing up there I've set up
there as a student today at the Met
they're rehearsing matinees up from
Milan with Diana Tamra and Vittorio
Grillo in the main roles and I'm really
excited that we're allowed to listen to
the rehearsal
to clear we are right and very lastly at
the top of net its miles away Peter Gelb
has been the general manager of the Mets
since 2006 Thank You audience and today
I'm allowed to run around all over the
place we've just been way way up there
to the gods it's actually sounds
fantastic up there thank you for today
it's amazing to be running around here
inside your beautiful Opera House thank
you you are not no I I see you here at
you're a second desk you have an office
but I mean the general manager that
you're in every rehearsal I heard it's
just a chance for me to keep my eye on
what's going on and you know to be
supportive when when necessary
people need my help if TV crews come in
and want a sudden interview so much for
that but it's really it's really that
there are there are many different
artistic factions that are working in an
opera
obviously there many moving parts so
things sometimes mean somebody at the
top to to intervene if a good table to
bang you know live in HD is your baby
and we are all very grateful that it's
an incredible institution and how many
countries is it shown and I was looking
it up yesterday it started off in just a
few countries it began this is the
nights in season which is coincides with
my ninth season next year will be the
10th anniversary of it and we began
relatively small as it has experiments
you thought normally begin small it was
in a few countries and maybe 35 or 40
theaters our first transmission which
was back in December of 2006 and since
then it has grown exponentially
we're now in 70 countries were in every
continent with the exception of
Antarctica typically on a on a Saturday
matinee in New York we're being seen
live from a huge geographical expanse
that ranges from the west coast of North
America where it's 10 o'clock in the
morning to as far east as Jerusalem in
Moscow where it is 8 or 9 o'clock in the
evening and all the time zones in
between and we're we have a movie
theater inside the Arctic Circle that
shows it live in tromsø Norway and we're
also in the southern tip of Argentina so
you know a huge deck geographic area and
then in those countries where the time
difference is too great like in Asia or
Australia or New Zealand they've seen on
a delayed basis a week or so away
maestro hi I'm Sarah Willis to meet you
you were disconnecting my colleague yes
Stefan don't we just did a whole second
horn concerto together we were so we
could meet you but would you let us in
we want to get down to the pit I didn't
know I didn't know that you had your own
private or I do Berenice climb over the
climb over the railings but to escape
we're now in the pit
and I am about to talk to the whole
section that the Metropolitan Opera
Orchestra is they spend most their life
in the pit of course but they're an
orchestra of their own right they have a
great website they play at Carnegie Hall
how many times they play at Carnegie
Hall a year guys three times a year it's
it's it's fabulous Orchestra check out
their website and now I've got the horns
horn players just have to meet all over
the world that's just how it is and but
the bit of you all in the way what's
life like in the pit I mean I was an
opera player for years I loved it and
you guys are an orchestra in your own
right there as well you do Symphony
Orchestra concerts and stuff yeah and
you are you happy to play in the dark
mists of time I mean it's hard to
complain when you have the most amazing
singers right next to you and an amazing
Orchestra and the horn section sitting
right right around you so it's pretty
amazing but I think in a way this is
sort of more community effort when
you're in the pit so you don't feel
quite so naked and I don't know I just I
really like the back and forth between
the singers we're really listening and
playing off of each other when you're on
stage it's like Oh any really great
moments of here in the pit I mean I had
one in Berlin when a tenor fell on us in
the dark he landed on the first tour and
think thank goodness not on me it was a
good one I remember there was like this
you know place where the horses come
across perfectly
this is what normal audience members
don't get to see all the stuff backstage
the German soprano Diana DeMayo and the
Italian tenor of Victoria regalo are
singing the lead roles in the Opera
what is the special thing about standing
on that huge stage and singing out into
this huge audience we are devoted to
when we are doing this is beautiful
artistry called opera and so I think
that whenever we are we don't think who
is in the other side you don't have to
think differently on the stage at the
Met then you do it you know a smaller
opera house no no we just have more
honking and more yellow cabs you can
hear that on the stage but from the room
yes you can hear it on the stage I can t
you know sometimes so I mean the
craziness of the CDs the changes by this
moment in New York be having such a
freezing weather user is and sometimes
warm and the temperature the changes
make a lot of you know a singer is a
human alive instrument so people whose
at home is not the are they performing a
score it's not that we have our feeling
we we you know we the emotions of
everyday life is through that we bring
it and we live it in the room but also
it's you know that we need to bring a
little bit of your life or something
Deanna
dynast Romano is client fantastisch wait
a year
du bist of a domestic evolved has a
feeling about the ISIS of decent
easement Bruno's oozing in is rising SOT
met is Hannigan Spiteri acoustic rehab
Thomas okay that the acetone pilfered me
more than man deep dish to me food and
food in that's automatic as man lean
indications I just come to us to work as
a Finn's super hunky named watts to sing
and this could feel declining we open
house I hope your mattress or acoustic
half minutes I submit its client
fantastisch in there poor boy don't
these are Collider Ronson what's with
all the clutter dress I've discovered so
many cool things at the Metropolitan
Opera today when you're sitting in your
seat there are subtitles built into the
seat in front of you for the operas so
that you know what's going on there's
even a big hall where you can go in if
you're late and you can watch the
performance that's going on and here at
the gift shop you can buy a lot of
fantastic things including costumes from
the production this one is from Carmen
that's all from Sara's music for today I
hope you enjoyed being at the Met as
much as I did if you can ever make it
here to here alive opera performance
then do and if you can't then just find
a cinema near you which starts the live
in HD broadcast
you'll love that I promise see you next
time on Sara's music and good bye from
New York
okay we're rocking now yeah
grabs Amelie thank you like the Jersey
party bravo Bravo
toy toy toy Vittorio grazie Mille